so Spiderman across the spider-verse has
some amazing cameos in it
here I come oh here I come
[Music]
there's one in here that completely blew
my mind and throughout this video I'm
going to be going through everyone who
cameos in the film and talking about how
deeply layered some of the Easter eggs
actually are this video won't be going
through every Spider-Man who appears in
the film and if you want to watch that
then we've actually done a full
breakdown on it linked right here
instead this is the big name actors that
go just beyond the suits and the things
from the comics can't wait to get into
it and if this is your first time here
I'm your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man this is the
heavy spoilers show and every day we
post big breakdown videos going over
movies and TV shows that's the kind of
thing you're into then make sure you
subscribe as we'd love to have you as
part of our spider Society see you chump
now a lot of the big cameos in the film
happen during a scene in which the spot
travels across the Multiverse through
using portals on his body there's lots
of different things yeah their time with
the overarching spider verse and even
things you think might be simple or very
complex as we watch him swim through the
black and white vibe he first he sticks
his head through a highly old-fashioned
Animated World when the plot leaks for
the film came out it said this was a
1930s style reality but I think it's
more likely just a nod to the 60s Comics
the character debuted an Amazing
Spider-Man 15 and this was released in
1962. it had a similar sort of art style
to what we see here with pop art and
almost a polka dot like thing that they
used to do with the colors not it's not
called polka dot but you know what I
mean now in this universe the spot pops
his head out and this frightens a woman
who smacks him over the head like it's a
like button in the background we can see
the flat iron and this is where the
daily beagle was located at in this
Spider-Man Remy films speaking of The
Daily Bugle we watch as the spot travels
into the Lego Universe which is where he
destroys its sign I love how this
universe is actually smaller than the
other ones because all the things here
are made out of Lego anyway though he
disappears we end up going back there
later on which is when we get a vocal
Cameo by JK Simmons J Jonah Jameson is
back and he pops up throughout the movie
way can hear him going off on the radio
shows and TV stations hello how JK plays
him across the entire spider verse and
when you think about it there's
absolutely no one else who could play
the media Mogul now you might notice in
the background of the office that
there's a doc Ox star at large newspaper
stuck up on the wall this is a nod to
the newspaper that appeared in
Spider-Man 2 when Doc Ock was racking up
Manhattan it's a really good continuity
detail and they actually made a Lego
version of this for the set so it's so
cool to see it here now this spot ends
up traveling into the Venom verse and we
actually get the designation of this
Earth in the universe and the comics
Spider-Man mutated into a monster but
for the movies it's clearly centered
around Eddie Brock well I say that but
we all know who everything revolves
around here that is Mrs Chen who makes a
live-action Cameo working in her store
he doesn't seem shocked at all to see
the spot dropping in and she's of course
seen Eddie's parasite eat someone so I
doubt anything surprises her anymore now
the scene I love the most in the movie
was when we see all the prisoners locked
up in the cells this had so many
different characters and we of course
had Spider-Man from the PlayStation 4
game there I wasn't sure about the Yuri
lowenthal who voices the character
dropped some lines here but he did
appear at the premiere for the film so
I'm guessing that he did I'll have to
double check on a second watch in a any
reason I can go back to watch this movie
I'm down now beside the PS4 version was
a little green man locked up and this
was actually the Green Goblin from the
old Atari 2600 this typeface as well and
I'm sure he hits the glass and it says
helvectia and displays it in that fun
zorino a real Rhino and a couple of
others but the big one comes with a cell
that miles takes a real pause at here we
get a live-action Prowler who's being
played by none other than Donald Glover
in case you don't know Glover has a lot
of big ties to the franchise that go
beyond just his homecoming MCU
appearance all the way back when the
Amazing Spider-Man reboot was being
talked about there were rumors that they
might take things in a different
direction and cast a black actor in the
role bear in mind that Spider-Man 3
released in 2007 and just five years
later we were gonna have a full-on
reboot there was a lot of talk that
they'd need to do something different so
it didn't make audiences feel like we
were getting the same sort of thing now
according to the rumors Glover's anxious
for the role and this to spark up some
interest for him he wore Spider-Man
costume on community this was during the
episode anthropology 101 and it's an
entry that Brian Michael Bend is just so
happened to see at the time he was
writing the seminal Ultimate Spider-Man
run which was a reimagining of the
character in which they reworked and
modernized a lot of his classic stories
at this point Brian Michael Bendis was
trying to find a way to bring in a new
version of Spider-Man and he created
miles after being inspired by Glover in
the show things would build on from this
and Glover then ended up voicing the
character in The Ultimate Spider-Man
cartoon there were thoughts that he
could eventually play the role but the
man had what happens to us all and that
he got too old to play a high schooler
how do you do fellow kids what about
Marvel wanted to give a little and he
was then cast as miles as uncle Aaron in
Spider-Man homecoming popping up at
several points in the movie he ended up
bringing up his nephew miles at one
point and this of course foreshadowed
that he'd play the prowler eventually
but looks like that has come true as we
catch him in the costume in the scene
which is such a cool Easter egg now to
go even deeper we've actually had a live
action Glover pop up in this
spider-verse before if we go back to
that first film then we could actually
catch that Aaron had the community
episode on screen when miles was at his
home so he had uncle Aaron watching a
scene that inspired his nephew's
creation who then went on to voice him
before before he played Aaron in the MCU
lots of different things going on here
but I absolutely love that they pulled
this all together and got him in this
scene I really didn't think that
live-action stuff would work alongside
this but yeah seeing it here yeah yeah
get me that live-action miles movie now
some of the voices we hear also have
their own cool attachment to them at one
point we get the spectacular Spider-Man
and his voice is provided by Josh Keaton
this is the the same guy who played him
in the animated series and it's so cool
they actually brought him across here
now originally it was thought that he
was gonna play Spider-Man in The
Animated what-if Zombies episode and
this was because a castless drop with
his name on it but that turned out to be
a lie and he was actually voicing Steve
Rogers instead Hudson Thames did
Spider-Man's voice but it's so cool the
scene across the spider-verse that they
pay tribute to him we also have a moment
in which dark oak pops up and we get
Alfred Molina's voice saying hello Peter
now with Andrew and Toby coming back for
no way home we were also obviously going
to get them in some form too though we
don't see them you know doing new stuff
specifically we do see some archive
footage of the pair with some big
moments from their films this is Andrew
watching Captain Stacy dying in The
Amazing Spider-Man films and Uncle Ben's
death scene happening in the Rainy verse
both on major moments for Spider-Man and
this comes to be the defining part of
their existence that's what this movie
is about too and I love how we have this
lace throughout every aspect effect of
the film you have the defining moments
as part of the plot but also the
defining moments who appear in the film
these actors and iterations of people
who've helped to establish Spider-Man as
the major character years in pop culture
these cameos are his Canon events too
and it's so cool watching all these
actors get some love and what's my
favorite Spider-Man film of all time
anyway I hope you enjoyed the video and
if there's any other cameos or people
who appeared in the film then make sure
you drop them below I have tried
pointing out all the vocal and live
action ones that I could hear but yeah
you know let me know I was blown away by
it and not paying attention the whole
time it wasn't crying yeah it was just
it was the dust in the cinema tonight
and I'm gonna complain now if you want
to support the channel for as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below and as a thank you
you'll get access to early videos every
week you also have a merch store over at
xeroedition.com which sells lots of
inspired t-shirts hats and more you've
also just launched a secret Invasion
slash Pulp Fiction inspired t-shirt so
if you want head over there and help us
out then the links in the description
you're gonna love it we're really proud
of this design now if you want something
else to watch then we have our breakdown
of the movie on screen right now which
goes over that ending scene and yeah
everything building up to it hell of a
lot to talk about and without the way
huge thank you for sitting through the
video I've been your host Paul and I'll
see you next time take care peace